10th grader and our teacher we had a
phenomenal teacher he was always
bringing in these controversial type
people
to address the class and we could ask
questions and stuff well on this day
he had the head of the american nazi
party come to our school
now understand you would never even you
couldn't even wrap your head around that
today
okay but it's 1970s things were
different
jesus yeah okay now the founder and the
original head of the american nazi party
was a fellow named george lincoln
rockwell
and and just by coincidence i had his
daughter
as one of my teachers a long time ago
and but you know she she renounced her
father she wanted nothing to do with
them
and she didn't even let you know that
that was her dad but it was what would
the head of the american nazi
society say to a group of 10th graders
i'm going to tell you well mostly
seniors
but george lincoln rockwell
he he was the founder and the original
head
vehement uh anti-semite and a racist he
was always getting into it with uh
martin luther king
and um he was murdered by one of his own
nazis that got into an argument on the
sidewalk outside his headquarters
and the guy shot him to death right
there on the sidewalk so anyway his
right hand guy
was a guy named matt cole koehl
and matt cole and his right hand guy
took over
martin kerr so they came to my school
that day
and um you know they're espousing all
these views of white supremacy
and i'm just sitting there listening to
him
and i've never heard an adult talk like
this before
and there's another black guy in the
class i mean there were more blacks in
the school but just two of us in this
particular class
and matt cole pointed at me and pointed
at my friend
and he said we're going to ship you back
to africa and then he went like this
and all you jews out there you're going
back to israel
now i just sat there staring at this guy
he wasn't scaring me but i was like
thinking
who gives this guy the right to to make
you know these these arrangements for me
you know and um i
i didn't challenge him because you've
got to understand my generation
we were raised to have respect for your
elders anybody who's older than you is
your elder
whether it's the postman the policeman
your neighbor the librarian whatever
if they're older than you they're your
elder you respect them you don't have to
accept what they say
but you respect them so i didn't i
didn't challenge him i just sat there
looking at him
and somebody piped up in my class and
said what happens if they don't go
or if they don't want to go and matt
cole says they have no choice
if they do not leave voluntarily they
will be exterminated in the upcoming
race war
now that was the first time i ever heard
the term race war
i've heard it a thousand times since
then but that was the first time i've
ever heard it i'm thinking to myself
what is this man talking about civil war
i mean that was over 1865
you know and he went on to say
that uh your uniform uh the color of
your skin will be your uniform
jesus yeah so then later that day i was
standing beside my locker
and matt cole and martin kerr were
leaving the school they you know they
hung around for a couple other potc
classes
so they come down the hallway and i'm
standing there and it's just
me and those two in the nazis in the
hallway right
and they didn't say anything to me but
they paused right in front of me
and i sneered at me leered at me and
then they started laughing
and they went on past me and run out the
door right
so i graduated two years later as a
senior and i went to howard university
and got my degree in music
you know music became my profession but
studying race relations on my own became
my obsession
and these two guys have propelled me
into that to really you know
dig into it a lot more what was that
feeling like being so young
and being um like treated like that by
two grown ass adults like
it was weird to see them talk like that
and and they were like you know vehement
about it
right you know i mean they were into
this belief
um i just didn't understand it
and so i even bought more books i i
continued to buy books
so i got this vast library on white
supremacy you know black supremacy all
kinds of stuff
and i read them all but none of the
books addressed why people became like
that
so um i graduated four years later with
my degree in music bachelor's degree in
music
and uh but you know i was always you
know tuning in to all kinds of racial
stuff right
so i found out about an unpublicized
demonstration rally that the american
nazi party was going to have see their
headquarters
was right near me over in arlington
virginia arlington virginia is about
35 40 minutes from where i live in
maryland okay just on the other side of
the potomac river from washington dc
okay okay they're gonna have an
unpublicized
rally in front of the white house across
the street in lafayette park
so if you know anything about lafayette
park
anytime you want to protest something
you go to lafayette park
there are people there 24 7. they've
been there for years
the people anti-nuke people the
environmental people
anti-abortion people you name it they're
there
and they're set up in the park facing
the white house so whoever is in the
oval office for whatever term
can look out the window and read their
billboards and whatever right right
okay so unpublicized means nobody knows
about it
except who they tell i managed to find
out
how did you find out somebody let me
know okay okay
and so uh it was gonna be a 12 noon like
a 15 minute
uh silent uh protest in front of the
white house
so now back then you could drive your
car up and down
the 1600 block of pennsylvania avenue
which is where the white house is
located
today you can't do that anymore only uh
law enforcement vehicles
and pedestrians you know you can walk up
and down there but you can't drive
because people have tried to ram the
gates of the white house
right so they so they put up concrete
pylons and stuff
you know that fold down into the street
with a remote control
so cop cars can come through there so
anyway uh
that thing you know you could drive
there so i went down there i parked my
car caddy corner
to the white house and i waited and sure
enough right up you know just just
before noon
this van comes and about 13 15 of these
guys get out
now this is eight years later 1982. okay
i saw them in 1974.
all right so um they get out
there's matt cole and martin kerr the
same two dudes you know because
they're still the head of the party
right right um
so they're lining up their little nazis
on the sidewalk
now there's nothing that uh that
indicated that they were nazis
you wouldn't know unless unless you knew
in advance right they didn't wear
gestapo uniforms or fly swastikas
they're all in dark black suits and
they're standing there like this
facing the white house right it's noon
time so lunch time
people like walking back and forth you
know not paying any attention because
there are other protesters in the park
too
so but nobody knew who these people were
they're just standing there facing the
white house the white house knew who
they were
so anyway i went for them to get all
lined up i got out of my car
i felt the need to confront matt cole
because when i was 15 i did not confront
him
and like i told you i was a child he was
an adult
he was my elder so now i needed to
confront him
um he was still my elder obviously okay
but the dynamic had changed in 1974 it
was child to adult
now it's adult to adult okay so i felt
the need to confront him
so i walked right up to him i said matt
cole
and he's some he like jumped back in the
line like oh my god who's this black
person you know
calling my name and um he says do i know
you
and i said well you spoke at my high
school and he said what high school
would that be
i said thomas wooten high school he
looked at me goes
oh yes yes yes i remember you
that was a long time ago what can i do
for you i said yes it was eight years
ago
he goes i remember how can i help you i
said do you recall what you told me
he nodded he goes yes what can i do for
you i said well i'm still here
he said well i can see that how can i
help you i said well you can tell me
just who the hell
gives you the authority to make
permanent travel arrangements for me
he says what's your name i said daryl
davis he put his hand out
he shook my hand i learned this
technique because i would apply it later
on
to another white supremacist he took my
hand and he held my hand in his hand
and he did not let it go and he started
pointing in my face with his other hand
like this
and he says mr davis you have to
understand one thing
it is in the interest of your race the
black race
to be a strong race and you cannot be a
strong race unless you are a pure race
and you cannot be a pure race if you are
miscegenating with other races
you went on and on about that then he
says it's in my interest
the aryan race which is what he calls
the white race to also be a strong race
and we must be a pure race we are
committing
genocide by miscegenating with mongrel
i'm sorry with mud races such as yours
we are becoming a
mongrel race so he calls anybody who's
non-aryan a non-white
a mud race and then that that
miscegenation causes them to be a
mongrel race
so he says the white race is committing
genocide by miscegenating with mud races
turning them into a mongrel race okay so
so until the races understand
uh that they must remain separate they
cannot coexist together
so you know he's going on on into this
stuff you know that i would hear a
thousand times
over the years and you were like 23
early 20s
uh yeah i just grabbed who i see uh 24
because i graduate 1980
at the age of 22. okay so it's in 1982.
so um now is that was that the gist of
the conversation you had with yeah
yeah and you know a few other things and
he he went back to the race war thing
it's called rahula r-a-h-o-w-a
rahuwa which stands for racial holy war
rahuwa and uh that's the white
supremacist term for the race war
and and they've added a new term now the
boogaloo same thing boogaloo or rojoa
means the race war
okay so anyway oh we talked about that
and you know i thanked him for his time
oh and i wasn't there to beat him up
yeah oh great voice i want to make sure
they can hear it oh thank you yeah i
wasn't there to beat him up you know i
was just there to
try to you know understand i'm trying to
learn from this guy
i'm not buying into i'm just trying to
learn where this comes from
so uh i thanked him shook his hand again
i left well a few months later they had
a publicized rally
they publicized that like about three
months in advance this is going to be
the american nazi party
recruitment rally the national
recruitment rally so they have nazis
from all over the country
come and gather right to recruit they
have like swastikas
now they have their swastikas okay
because
the first one was unpublicized
there were no police there or anything
like that had it been publicized
protesters were to come and beat the
crap out of them all right
so this one was publicized even months
in advance people were like writing
letters to uh
the dc mayor and you know don't give
them a permit blah blah blah on and on
and on
but you know you have to give them a
permit you know they have the right to
freedom of speech and freedom of
assembly and all that kind of thing
just like anybody else does so they come
this time they got police protection
because there were probably about 50 of
them my secretary and i went down there
to this thing you couldn't get close to
them the police had formed a human ring
circle around them all right and with
their shields their batons like this
there were no less than about ten
thousand ten thousand
protesters for these like maybe 50 nazis
and matt cole comes with martin kerr and
they all are now wearing
their gestapo uniforms flying swastikas
going
zig aisle high hitler white power you
know they're taunting the
the crowd so people came with bricks and
baseball bats and chains
and they rushed the police and the
police were like pushing them back
so then they began taking their
projectiles and throwing them
over the heads of the police to land on
one of the nazis
you know in the circle right and so the
police put up the tear gas began tear
gassing everybody
and it became mayhem my secretary and i
were just standing there
and the police beat us with their night
sticks just for standing there it became
hysterical i mean it got out of control
i said come on let's get out of here so
we left
and uh back then you only had uh nbc cbs
and abc there was no cable
and um we're watching the news
now people like turning over police cars
bashing off the windows
kicking out the lights setting buildings
on fire the whole nine yards
so we're watching the our local nbc
affiliate for um
for the news and uh there's matt cole in
the studio
yeah and he's saying and they're showing
footage of all the mayhem you know we
even saw ourselves walking by
and he was you see you see it's the
blacks and the jews
who who are denying us our right to
freedom of assembly denying us our right
to freedom of speech
you don't see any nazis turning over
police cars and setting fires the blocks
on the jews
this country is run by zog zog zog
what does that stand for it's an acronym
for a zionist occupied government
that's their big word all right so it
means everything is run by the jews
so they blame the jews for everything
and black people are the pawns of the
jews
because black people are not as smart as
the jews in the in their minds
you know we're dangerous but we're not
as smart as the jews so they're more
dangerous
so they call it zog okay so anyway
um i'm listening to him
and i realize this guy is pretty smart
he's shrewd he's smart because i
couldn't figure out why on earth
would he have his national recruitment
rally in washington dc
washington you know washington dc is
two-thirds
black the nickname for washington dc is
chocolate city
okay washington dc is two-thirds black
there are no black people in dc
that want to be recruited into the net
into the nazi party
you want publicity huh well yeah and
certainly
you know there are no jews in dc or
anywhere else right that want to join
the american nazi party
so why would he do it there i got it
because he knew this would happen he
knew
this would happen and and it would
further his cause
he would have official news footage
of blacks and jews wreaking havoc
turning over police cars bashing out
stuff
destroying the city he would take that
nbc cbs abc news footage
go out to the to the pacific northwest
idaho montana
you know washington state oregon right
and said look you see what's going on in
our nation's capital
the blacks and the jews are taking over
zog is taking over our country
come join us we're going to take our
country back and that works
they see that and they come and join
it's a recruitment tool
all right because you know if nobody
riot it wouldn't do any good right
okay so that brought the news cameras
out exactly exactly
so uh so that was that
foreign